and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners win that was mine thank you very
much
how are you guys full studio full of
friends joining us in studio is the one
only creme Matthews everybody how are
you bud yeah yeah good to be here
black me I feel an epic episode coming
on we're gonna go do the option whatever
the Lakers did last night in that game
in front of us you see we always a hot
pile acres
bye Lakers okay we'll get into that Bob
wooden from us this series of hats our
good friend Garnett from Canada busts
all hat chat snag went a little early
and I found a good deal on him when I
purchased them for a while these few
dollars you look at this it goes with
your shirt everything goes with that
shirt though by the way these are
Arizona State hats yeah you know we went
to Arizona State yeah good friend Brody
Stephens that's when I purchased them I
figured everybody in the studio deserved
at Arizona State hat thank you and I'm
one today I'm sorry it's everybody's
favorite artistic lesbian he's here for
the show he's gonna hang out it's
artistic lesbian Hey Dude grab a hat oh
look at that
grab a hat these are gonna water -
ladies and gentlemen Johny Woodard is in
the building
who do you think was in Arizona State
yeah yeah Garnett it's give you one day
and I purchased them in and it was a
sunny day when I turned my internet on
that's supposed to be yellow or Excel up
dog Forks up guys thanks for tuning in
Jason where you gonna be
well I'll be at your thing tonight for
Brody at the coma story we are 28
tickets out of being two sold-out shows
the
come to that all the money goes to help
Brody's family and no no no it goes to a
very specific thing it's a mental it's
the comedy stores mental health
organization they opened up of course I
don't have it on me I will get Dana to
do that but that's where all the money's
going
that's all the money goes that's where
his family decided they want oh is that
right family is going through a process
right now they said they they appreciate
everything yeah we're gonna figure out
Oh what where they're gonna what are
they gonna do it but right now this my
is going to come so Comi sores going
Mental Health Awareness know shut up I'm
reading the flow oh don't read the flyer
god don't ever read the flyer why would
you hire the benefits actually not about
Brody Stevens he's on the flyer
about Bobby Lee we're raising money for
Bobby Lee
Bobby Lee presents Sam Tripoli's pretty
stupid I just said it and it here in
Minnesota Minnesota Minneapolis at the
Mall of America but the House of Commons
it's a great gig when you there this
weekend so headlining babies great dude
man vortex like I got you got 100 so bad
he was cold for me
Minnesotans thought it was cold but the
cool thing is you only outside from the
airport but we don't have to come see
your show ah you're onto something but
they know about I'm willing to predict
me no one's gonna show up ears no no
they travel they do not go see CHED's
all proceeds go to Brody Stevens it's
only Meyer green Reagan be um just
follow me on Instagram I'm looking for
people to follow me on Instagram well I
actually handle I tagged him on the
reaming sorry I mean uh no no I tagged
him on the map Strunk so go ahead
at Cory Matthews man everything runs
through there
everybody's got coffee and I love your
Instagram Joe you have a funny Instagram
thanks grams in the history of I
appreciate that what what's the part
again and Cory Matthews make this happen
it's like the WorldStarHipHop of comedy
on instagram follow my follow each other
ok guys here are my things I hope I'm
here we go everyone's not going to enjoy
right now Sam a cream shell obviously
tonight is our show March 7th and Sam
Tripoli's filthy friends at the Hard Val
Long Beach ok heart Long Beach harvelle
in Long Beach just go to Google harvelle
Long Beach or you can go to my website
this weekend Friday it is March 8th I am
at the Spokane comedy club the Spokane
comedy club its tinfoil hat with Eddie
Bravo myself there's a March 8th 10 p.m.
show and then the following day is
simple a comedy night at the Tacoma
comedy club and that is a 4:30 show so
we have Spokane on Friday and we have
Tacoma on Saturday comedy chaos will be
the following week and then I'm in New
Jersey that is March 16th headlining
Tiff's comedy club with my man XG that's
mark 16:1 gene said he's coming out and
then at the end of the month I am we are
doing the waking Arizona tour we are
we're in Arizona that is the 28th we're
at the house of comedy for Tim for a
comedy night and then the 29th we are in
Tucson and we are at the we are at the
one nine one tool and that you can find
all those dates at Sam sharply calm you
doing low me you got it I do once a
month and Long Beach I'll put you next
one oh yeah all right you're on guys
that's been punched up enjoy the rest of
your weekend great night hope you all
die that was the layup line
laughs warming up last night was a was
Clippers versus Lakers and I watched it
and I have to be honest with you I'm a
die-hard clipper fan I love magic
Johnson Shaq so those are mine cream
those are my legs they love I felt bad
for the Lakers last night oh that team I
know this orga not matter we need one
more so we're gonna put you right there
actually right there oh you want right
there okay put it right there put it
right there just grab that chair what
dates you got what do you got okay
the the organization that we are
donating all the money to is the
National Alliance of mental illness it
is a connoisseur organization that what
are you doing you crazy person that we
are running so uh you can donate that if
you want to go to the GoFundMe right now
I'll Brody Stevens go fund me go fund
Brody Stevens go [ __ ] me go far Brody
Stevens go fund me okay a lot of work
going on right here a lot of work okay
if you put him Brody Steven go fund me
it's Brody Stevens believe it fund and
it is almost up to 15 grand
all that money again goes to the comics
organization welcome fight Danny how are
you many many many many things new would
you like a Brody Stephens hat who told
you this would you like this Oh tonight
Oh tonight you're not going why aren't
you coming to Brody's thing though
because I'm working why did you hate
Brody today would you like one no I'm
the Internet Jeff might want one okay
why why you act like a man you roadkill
right now that's all there we go I just
need you from one side of the tea
to the other complete other side of the
table you know and I'm sorry once again
I'm sorry um we fix it so she's kind of
in the picture cuz I mean we we want
people masturbating to just the four
yeah there's like a creepy something to
jerk off to so where did you watch the
fights oh you want to get to five we're
gonna talk Lakers real quick before we
go into your Lakers Clippers if this
actually ties in Newsweek's reporting
right now LA Lakers are almost certainly
set to fire Luke Walton at the end of
the season Gracie that could see that's
the thing I felt like that move for to
save this season that move needed to be
made at the all-star break but at the
all-star break is when I felt like he
had lost control it could have been
saved Bron James is a coach killer
he killed coaches he has done this and
with the exception of Miami and Miami is
the only place but he wanted that coach
fired both a hot seat Riley stepped in
yeah see that's what happened here
Jeanne bus saved Luke I'm saying cuz
magic wanted is here cuz that's not
Magic's coach and you're not gonna go
down with a coach you didn't hire well
manager is doing a great job
everywhere old regime coach yeah he's
gone about to be gone because if they're
if they're [ __ ] up you're not gonna
lose your job on a deal is that you're
sure no Sun right job yeah that do is go
doing a great job that's one thing
that's not but that's where I'm where
that's it's very rare that your cookie
winning team with the coach and you
here's the biggest problem is that Luke
Walton is basketball royalty because his
father he played on some champion played
and watch and that's why Jeannie didn't
want him fires were in this season
because look at what happened in
football but we could talk about that
I gotta tell you something last night I
when I was watch that game I go either
they've get or I mean there was no
organizational don't have my ready
giving up they've given up like I
thought the Milwaukee I think it was New
Orleans they played the game before
Milwaukee when they lost that game I
felt like it was a rat you know I mean
like they can't they can't beat anybody
like they were favored last night
against the Clippers and then they were
nobody knows why and then they were
favored the night the game before that
against the Sun everybody said those
sparks would be favored against us but
they lost those games yeah LeBron James
played 42 minutes had 27 points eight
rebounds six assists and go ahead no I
was gonna say and that's my next thing
LeBron has the most unimpacted numbers
I've ever seen because I realize those
numbers should win a game well I mean
LeBron the best player in the league
he's averaging twenty seven eight and
eight and we're the same team we were
last year last year we were the 11th
seed this year with a 10 C with
supposedly the best player everything
hey if you look at all stoppers routine
nothing if you look the top two teams
from last year in the East which were
who Toronto Cleveland Cavaliers the top
two players of both of those teams have
gone to the West San Antonio is that a
seed and [ __ ] LeBron is the 10th seed
I mean that tell it like how garbage
Stewie things last year now it's not
right and LeBron would have an almost
impossible task of getting to the finals
this year knees because there's those
teams are stacked well here's the thing
and in kairi's causing noise in Boston
right now right can you imagine the two
could just make it work we could add a
dynasty even still right but these prima
donnas these egomaniac that grass is
greener like [ __ ] lebron would never be
a part of a dynasty he has too much
power if you let's I've says before if
you take magic cha if you take Michael
Jordan and Tom Brady versus Peyton
Manning and LeBron James I mean the
talents probably equal the difference is
Michael Jordan Tom Brady
let football basketball people make
decisions paint Manning and LeBron James
made all the decisions I ever thought of
that it's a great analogy it's just the
truth man they let people do things
LeBron James has never done that and you
know what man you and I we're all in
we're all in LA we got a million plates
spinning and we're [ __ ] exhausted now
imagine being LeBron James you have two
TV shows going an Internet show going
your honor late dude
it's too much man yeah I mean I don't
you know that's the side park the [ __ ]
he's doing off the field is one thing
there's an another thing but I just I
can't seeing him every day dude like
really dropped him a notch to me in my
ranking of him oh he was never even
all-time to me but just where I think he
see the thing was I'm from Cleveland and
he won that championship and I thought
breaking the Cleveland curse would set
him over as like you won the biggest
championship you can ever win I don't
even see it that way anymore
ya know I mean cuz this sees it like
he's not a leader you know I mean he's
not a little exposed man and his numbers
are so unimpacted I just can't believe
that he he's doing these numbers 27 8
and 8 and we're the same team like we
could have say we could assign julius
randle
let LeBron go and had this same season
you know and save 24 million dollars
yeah hey man when Russell Westbrook does
it everyone's like Oh Judy just stats
stuffing and when LeBron James does it's
like no I'm not gonna give him a pass I
mean I don't know about Russell because
Russell's never want anything so his
numbers are kind of like if you know
hollow numbers too but I'm not giving
LeBron I can't give LeBron a pass this
season man like his numbers just had no
impact like part of that is because of
him not being a leader the other dudes
aren't motivated like they don't want to
help LeBron yeah well they don't like
him he tried to trade all that right the
way he treats them too though like he's
always yelling at cools my Ingram oh my
god tell you dude it's like I've been in
Hollywood enough I've seen
what are you doing right I was gonna
read you a tweet that I put on
punch-drunk sports you can follow him on
Instagram thank you then Colin Colin
Cowherd had the best week LeBron has
spent the season putting himself above
his teammates words and actions
separating himself from everyone
countless side projects never truly
buying into his HC part of the
leadership is getting over yourself and
getting into others Congrats on your
cool TV show and movie projects though
yeah I'm telling you bro you don't come
to the Lakers and [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
man they burn you a steak and White
House just gonna I was just gonna say I
hate to make this comparison but this is
what Dwight did yeah oh my bad mother
you just got yelled at I said - how many
thought that was a little racist of Erin
real quick all right I've never seen him
yell at me when I do that a black guy
does it suddenly it's an issue did he do
it when RuPaul Ruben Paul was on because
he's a lot like skins more like in his
defense Erin's not racist but his wife
is in the Klan is that true Aaron your
wife cook on Klan right but that doesn't
mean he's raised yes it's not data races
but I am NOT right ah but no that's a
great comparison
I don't think LeBron is on that level
but that's the same attitude that the
white hat coming here like when when
Colin Cowherd is going after you that
means you're an open target he is such a
like corporate like follow the line guy
like that's what he does because he
works for ESPN no he does he works for
Fox I matter okay
oh no no no you're allowed to mess up
here like none of your take all right
Manny your tape
yeah you were here last week yeah that's
when you get that's our good friend
Scott I mean uh what's your name Johnny
Woodard got it for Scott I don't know
Scott Ross just popped into my hat
you missed it Tebow and I both went into
the penalty box when Sam was doing his
plugs yeah we're like a buddy cop team
right here so I feel bad for and dude
next year he bettered like he has to yes
that Redemption well they gotta get
somebody supposedly that was his thing
he was gonna bring in some free agent
and hoping that nobody wants to play
with him he didn't destroy gaming laws
desperately tried to play with them they
just wouldn't let him I don't think
Davis is gonna want to come here dude I
still would be clearly dead yeah a man
now I think he's open now let me tell
maybe maybe other thing get Kyrie
because no please let's not redo that
cuz they were seeing tyloo - I was here
Tyler
Tom don't do three words JJ reddick him
- you know 20 is the cosmetic on the
[ __ ] maker I love it is the Cavs just
won two games and they're having a blast
Kevin Love is back from injury and
they're all hugging each other like each
other they are Smith yeah well he's at
home he's gone he's gone and they they
announced that the Lakers have
officially stopped talking to Mel it's
done dude they knew it was done but and
it would only add gas to the fire but I
mean come on we knew we weren't signing
Melo like do we have to make an
announcement about that the Lakers are
no longer interested into white how it
either yeah well I mean uh I mean Melo
is a LeBron boy he's banana boat but
again like you were saying LeBrons not a
good gym he's not coach and think about
this was he one day only professionals
own a franchise yeah I feel bad for
whatever franchise that guy buys because
you're looking at sorry Johnny
you're looking at Michael Jordan [ __ ]
hater Charlotte Bobcats garbage Gary
Jeter in the Marlins
what yeah I know they had to change name
because he ran that brand so bad through
the ground it's kind of like when Bayer
got rid of Monsanto so like this is
garbage naina hey have you guys seen
that barbershop show on HBO with LeBron
Oh everybody says it's so dumb everybody
agrees it's like they're talking about
that about on the radio thing you go to
a barbershop
you're not even know agree you don't
know anything about sports no you're
right let me read that like it's like
people are saying like that's not
barbershop like people don't all agree
they all yell at each other and like
this is like hey the problem what's your
take
I like that take if they all agree on
that's a hell of a barbershop you know I
mean nothing but celebrities like that's
a barbershop quartet they work together
he's like he's like the new Oprah like
he has all these people on going through
something like you had Antonio Brown he
had Anthony Dame Anthony Davis defense
yeah any but he puts him over he's like
Oprah used to do back in the day is he
putting them over it's a PR move well I
mean he's gonna let him real quick if he
starts [ __ ] rocking the boat too much
they're gonna put bigger rock at the
Banana Boat yeah man if this season has
been over that's what I keep emphasizing
it wasn't even these last couple nights
like I'm telling you around the all-star
break you could start to seep dudes let
go of the rope and in the NBA
once dudes let go of the rope like if
they don't get along its V I mean it's
been a handful of teams that didn't like
each other in one
well Kobe Shaq Lakers but this you
basically gotta have the best dude
exactly well here's the thing we don't
have that every one of these guys on
this team up until this moment was
dominating whatever team they were they
were the Alpha they were the son in
which everything around that team
[ __ ] gravitate to college high school
all that [ __ ] AAU all that here they're
on a team and a guy who's a little bit
bigger a little big alpha says trade all
this garbage you think they won't play
for that guy
right now you think they want that guy's
legacy to get better I mean you were
telling me that LeBron James during the
all-star break was like kisstixx guys
and got on a plumb [ __ ] plane and
took off with two bottles of wine yeah I
know TMZ [ __ ]
yeah and then it was that one game where
he came to the game with wine like where
he wasn't playing but was drinking wine
or waiting out in the press box and he
sat on the bed with a glass of wine I
was like what
dude he's doing coke in the tunnels yeah
it's true he can pull that [ __ ]
Cleveland they're like oh that's so
great wine is good for you that's why
he's drinking it you know like they had
the trade LeBron is what you're saying
but that's not gonna happen
yeah I don't think he deserves to be a
lot be interesting when he retires cuz
he's a big boy like do you think he goes
like fat hmm where do you go does he go
Michael Jordan kind of sloppy sloppy
Jordans no man whoa and plus they did
say LeBron put like 20 pounds on he got
up to like two eighty during that month
that he was out cuz he's drinking
non-stop
yeah that's not he's in that barbershop
drinking vodka
I'm swear to god he's drinking a lot
like that's the one dude will never use
sound effect [ __ ] breaking news nope
you're not getting in
breaking news LeBron James might have a
drinking problem coming from a guy who
has a drug problem okay
go down what is oh that's when they
started putting on a mm up Jordans drink
it to you Jordan also alcoholic well
yeah I'm gonna go out on a limb and say
all black people are alcoholics sorry oh
yeah I forgot I was gonna say I agree
though let's ask Scott what's going on
over there the sidelines Scott my
alcohol is the one thing that can have
that kind of effect on your game though
as a basketball player you can smoke and
ya won't have that they all do bloody
Deluxe right drinking note that actually
could you know that's
that's the that slows you down yo yeah
you can't who's totally mean LeBron's
mine he thinks his legacies intact he
can do whatever at this point that's not
a good idea in LA you know honestly I
think he came to the west so he's an
excuse so he doesn't have to go to the
finals he got tired of going to the
finals he doesn't want to go to the
finals he went out to the playoffs he
wants to play till he's 40 I think he
thought he was gonna go to the playoffs
though at least I mean when he was
healthy they were the four seed I mean
so that to me that shows that they dig
they they were okay they could play I
just feel like no he probably thought he
was gonna go to the playoffs get
eliminated in one and I can just have my
summer off right and relax but I drink
the season not this no playoff [ __ ] it's
unacceptable yo it is for $35,000,000
for years as like cold as the history of
racism and all that [ __ ] the one thing I
love about Boston is like they have an
idea it's like if it ain't winning tear
it down they have no problem we're
tearing look what they did Isiah Thomas
the Lakers the Lakers just think that
they are not part of the natural cycle
of sports which is like you're up at
some point and you're down now we have
been down no we coming off of a row [ __ ]
on it to stop it he wasn't doing that we
went through it we were just drafting we
got like five number two picks on the
team and we felt like at this we had the
young core and we felt like at this
point we add this now we can add this
veteran piece and he can get us over the
top
we haven't been coming with a bunch of
random ass free agents like we you know
we come in with our young dudes
Lonzo Kuzma ain't neither our traffic
that's what we try to do right nany your
thoughts that's what we try to do and
you don't understand any of this and the
Bron James podcast and not get that we
talked already even though we hate them
and love them we talk about LeBron an
hour and episode
we don't know why that's what I'm good
at mating like kids are screaming I'm
like oh I can't even hear that that
nobody talks about I was one of the
original guys who burnt LeBrons Jersey
yeah I've had a SportsCenter they've
done pieces on me so I'm a LeBron James
expert because I've destroyed a great
thing to be so the UFC fighting
championship whoa whoa we're moving on
Chad does he decided I was trying to get
guys um guys there's a lot of great
sports coming out there's a lot of great
stuff coming out boxing Johnny and I
were talking about going some boxing
matches we love everybody to show to
join us and we're gonna grab our tickets
at sea geek that's right
sea geek one of our top sponsors on the
show we go there use a promo code punch
drunk drunk okay it's with four R's
punch drunk you get $10 off your first
purchase man do they have cockfighting
yes they do do they do have cockfighting
you can go what they saw is that Luther
let me see let me see if it's ruther
yeah just keep going
bring them on um so they got everything
we're going to see boxing you're gonna
go see our live of vets
MMA pro wrestling Bert crushers on here
somewhere you can go see bird cries over
him go watch why don't you go and watch
odd the funeral that is the laker the
Russell Laker season spring training
baseball Birds tickets are expensive
well Bert's got a packed house I know
it's amazing
dude I can't wait till he comes back
down so I can hang out with him again oh
jesus that is Chad sumac and Chad you
might owe me feels that on the promo
code is punch-drunk $10 off we're gonna
go boxing where you'll see live events I
want everybody to get on their phone
more please because I'm working no one
is picking up do it again do it again so
that is our good friends cream I'm sure
there's a Shack all-star comedy event
you can go to
ooh uh are you soccer guy yes you wanna
go see galaxy does anyone go see the
galaxy I used to go to David Beckham was
there
I like Elias you really go watch out fun
yeah funded hey joining us while we
discuss this whole thing is a sports
Andy Ruth or how are you Andy good how
are you guys doing doing great doing
great um what's your favorite events to
go see life my favorite of well I'm
actually about to see spring training
next week which I'm pretty excited I
said not oh you're gonna go see are you
seeing Dodgers or Arizona they're you
which I'll see some Dodgers you know I'm
a Moretz and in from Cincinnati so I
think I'm gonna go to the Dodgers red go
see go see Puig in that red jersey oh
I'm so pissed we traded them you're from
Cincinnati I'm from Cleveland Indians
which Cleveland since a makes Cleveland
look like New York City that city so
[ __ ] Shady
there's nothing shadier than Cincinnati
I went to a [ __ ] I went to a Chipola
I felt like I was in the wire I'm like
dude people getting shanked in the
[ __ ] corner people throwing their
phones no you and I say those condos you
remember it looked like the wire yeah
yeah I saw a drug deal go down cuz you
were buying drugs listen okay so go to
see geek use the promo code punch drunk
and grab those tickets go hang out
ruther and Arizona Reuther ah so what
are you gonna do with this bet right now
it's looking like Clippers might make
the playoffs
Lakers might not what are your opinions
on that my opinion is I'm gonna have to
buy me myself a Kobe no means no Jersey
and wear it to Staples Center well I
respect your game on that now listen
your thoughts on what is going on with
the Lakers you're here with Cory
Matthews if you ever need a guy on your
podcast he's wonderful he's got a great
Instagram go check it out at Cory
Matthews on Instagram he is a die-hard
Laker fan and what do you think happened
in the season dude cuz I know you love
to suck on LeBron's nuts hard those big
[ __ ] [ __ ] black nuts that you like
the mouth you know cuz he still
number one in your world of the greatest
of all time I mean look dude blame goes
all around on this game yes I mean they
tried to get rid of their entire roster
and it didn't happen and I mean they're
not coming back from that LeBron didn't
play 18 games look at the record before
LeBron gets her the bronze numbers
aren't any different than what he's been
doing in recent seasons so look my
opinion on the Bron really hasn't
changed you can say what you want but oh
and I will they don't like that go ahead
go ahead Tripoli but the fact remains he
went to eight straight Eastern
Conference Finals and he joins this team
and they don't they don't stir threes
they don't play any defense the coach is
suspect I think we can all agree at this
point but yeah they're probably not
gonna make the playoffs I'm just very
out the playoffs is out because they've
given up you know saying they're not
trying to win games yeah by the way did
you see that one play with his teammate
push LeBron to play D yeah coach them
cool and that's the one dude like I feel
like he's on Kuzma the most you know I
mean Ingram second but like he rides
cools my heart man like that's you gotta
bring him the bronze pulling [ __ ]
small-market [ __ ] in the bright
lights and it's like dude they hide that
[ __ ] in Cleveland cuz they need you
right these dudes not gonna go Lakers as
bigs of Lakers are and they are big I
think the only thing bigger Lakers are
the Dodgers that's just my opinion
Lakers are taller
Thank You Chad oh god damn man I don't
want to do it but I just feel like I
have to wow you just got put into the
penalty box without even put the pill
map but here's the thing outside the
Dodgers and the Dodgers are big but I
mean we have Hollywood I mean we have
everything it's time these are stars are
so much bigger than LeBron James is a
huge star it's like you came in here
trying to pull some [ __ ] and you
have like the ghost of of Kareem playing
there the ghost of Shaq matter Johnson
Kobe Bryant and like dude you're not the
biggest guy
family hopper said what do you mean
tried to pull wait what do you mean
tried to pull some [ __ ] what does
that mean you know trying to get the
coach fired trying to get the [ __ ]
team mates plane blaming everybody but
himself
that works in Cleveland when you you're
the best [ __ ] biggest chip the
biggest name in the state okay yeah I
actually had had to roll with Sam over
here that just got me points as number
three favorite Laker of all time to
smile for pushing lady [ __ ] right that
is what that is a sign of where LeBron
James is respected on that team well hey
dude hey listen we do know a great
leader okay
does not throw his [ __ ] teammates
under the bus and try to trade everybody
if you want that you let the fleet see
the problem the problem with LeBron is
he thinks he's bigger than the
management there he doesn't allow
anybody to make basketball still he
makes all the decisions he got Rondo he
got [ __ ] Lance Stephenson he got all
these guys who can't [ __ ] shoe on his
team he made those decisions and that
when they don't work out he blames
everybody but himself and this has
happened every time in Cleveland but he
was playing in a [ __ ] the d-league
which is the e suck my dick we want a
championship we should build a wall
around LeBron Kobe Kobe the difference
is no cuz people always say that like
Kobe was yelling at players too but then
the difference would be Kobe would get
the ball and win the game yummy like
that's what LeBron [ __ ] rott no no no
no no no Kobe LeBron first of all time
in comparison like it's actually
offensive to compare Kobe to it's like
I'm offended right now you sing
insanity offender there are three times
in LeBron James life that we have seen
him
check out this to me to me that [ __ ] you
to me that shows how an impactful your
bronze number but killer instinct which
is first of all winning game it's no
it's not after in LA and that's why to
me I this year shows how unimpacted
LeBrons numbers are like when he gets
twenty seven nineteen and eight or
whatever he had and we want my bad about
the table and we lose to the sun's to
Phoenix like the greater the best player
in the league's shouldn't have those
numbers and his team loses to me that
death show the impact his numbers don't
have the impact and to me that comes
because his teammates aren't with him
yeah to like he's not lazy
alienated every by so with those numbers
you need though you need your team to
help you over the table it's crazy as
Isaiah Thomas's the one thing he ever
said the original Isiah Thomas
he's like basketball is not about the
court it's about the locker room and
that's where you win t and great teams
can fall because locker room at each
other and okay teams could do way better
when they love each other he alienated
everybody he can do that in Cleveland he
can't do that in [ __ ] the Lakers lot
as much as I'm a clipper Lakers are the
[ __ ] Kings we [ __ ] know that and
it's [ __ ] you can't do that dude you
are following people
Magic Johnson Kareem Shaquille Kobe
James Worthy these are [ __ ] all times
great stock you are one of them you not
bump any of em dog they all have more
championships in you right the end of
the day don't keep bringing up teams
that Robert Horry has special titled is
he okay teams that [ __ ] is such dudes no
it's it's bass it's so bass when we
bring up team stats where the Jersey
goodbye I just I can't hear him no it's
just like he's talking out of his
[ __ ] ass yeah
we have the same argument he'd like dude
there are three times that [ __ ] Kobe
just quit and we know it's when he found
out his mom was getting banged by
Delonte West okay Brown you mean the
LeBron quit yeah and then we know he
quit laughs last Finals got that
triple-double in the first game and then
just disengaged I can't remember the
specific times he disengaged lying he we
used to hear him crime where it why
isn't he showing up we did couple times
I don't know this piece of time so I
can't list them and then he is [ __ ]
quitting right now oh no no dude the
Kuzma pushed him there's a sign nobody
on that team respects I know doing this
I mean and but again I keep saying this
[ __ ] really started at the all-star
break at the all-star break when when I
was when I was like these dudes have let
go of the rope you know like they're not
together anymore yeah that's the guy
who's who [ __ ] it's why nobody wants to
play with Kobe I mean play with brah
because they all the league all knows if
it goes bad he throws you under the bus
this is typical we see this in comedy
all the time dude like there's that dude
who's like got all the tail and just
doesn't work well with everybody and he
just alienated and eventually it gets
worked out no matter how good he is he
gets worked out of the scene cuz nobody
needs that bitch-ass [ __ ] no I mean I
seeing it every day like that's the part
that really pushed me over the edge like
I had these feelings about him when he
was in Cleveland like this is the [ __ ] I
would bring up when he was in Cleveland
welcome back but seeing it every day
dude is just like I can't believe how I
mean and I feel part of the numbers
being on impact for us cuz know
everyone's not with him
you know nobody they don't want him they
do not do you think Brandon Ingram wants
to see LeBron Nathan right right or
Kuzma you know me aku's know someone
because I'd have everybody getting good
press in LA Kuzma always got they're
like this guy's an impact player he
plays well the fact he pushed him lets
me know in the locker room there's a
whole different vibe going on and dude
nobody gives a [ __ ] about your rings in
the east
it just doesn't dude I mean the I mean
the not making the playoffs yo like
that's the part that's so [ __ ]
humiliating if we would like a you know
a 6 or 7 C we lose in the first round
okay you know we making strides but
literally this is the same season we had
last year yeah can we uh you all keep
saying the east and this week and all
that can you give him props and not he
came back 3-1 deficit on the Golden
State Warriors from the greatest well
I'm going to tell you something of all
time that's some magic right there
because what draymond Green did there
was not worthy of getting suspended and
he did it because it's LeBron James and
listen the [ __ ] NBA knew if the Bron
James lost that series that legacy is
[ __ ]
he's lost way more than he won this
Collette back out him at 3 3 he was at 3
3 500 he goes on losing next two at that
point he needed to win that that series
in order for him to go you take the NBA
care dude he at that point was enough
dude wherever you put him on people
watch dude draymond Green should have
been kicked out the series before when
he [ __ ] Crane kicked Steve Adams in
the nuts
so what does the NBA Mei do now that
LeBrons kind of pulling these antics
wait why do you think I can't wait kids
I am Williams I am with a new one and
now the Lakers are in the Zion
sweepstakes do they have their own in
the lottery - they're never gonna put
dye on with logo so they're gonna put
him on a team I thought New York I'm
telling you right now we have a chance
at Zion we have never had we have now a
aren't we in the lottery they're not
gonna let them poison me now enter the
desire and sweep you're now in desire no
we in there yeah we gonna have balls
I know Cleveland's knocking again
because we got in like nine first round
traffic yeah it's not gonna happen again
it's gonna be us or Phoenix Phoenix
Phoenix out for New York New York why do
you think you're seeing that the
Coliseum again stolen no selling the
team dude the NBA gets after a while
they're like okay you're hurting our
brand you're gone and asked
he's gonna offer them by Bill for that
team after they got Ewing the NBA's like
we not giving y'all the number-one
people you're crazy ah so that's it we
did enough LeBron James talk Jason UFC I
felt was crazy that was an hour so I
think we should talk about UFC for an
hour okay I'm fine with it
that was the LeBron James hour I want to
talk bowling UFC crazy fights I mean
does does Jon Jones solidify himself as
one of the greatest ever I mean does the
steroid thing taint his his his legacy
so much that you eat to me it does it
does it'll always be in the back of her
head it wasn't with Wes Welker this is a
different sport uh is it enough even
more physical though well I mean I I'm
with you but like look at how steroids
are treating baseball versus football
it's just like no it is but I'm saying
okay so how about football versus USC
with steroids that you don't think USC
fighters need to use I think I mean I
personally like you think it may like if
you heard someone uses it like that
throws everything out like that for you
in UFC it's just weird because you know
he's supposed to be talented so beyond
these guys and he gets busted on the two
dudes he beat the guy that he beat twice
he's the only guy to ever beat that guy
and both times he's busted first Sara so
it's to me it's like I don't know how to
take that ya know I mean I feel you I
think it it does taint but I just feel
like in those kind of sports you know
and those heavy physical contact sports
like that I'm like man whatever you need
yeah that's across the board I mean who
knows though you I mean who knows like
yeah he got caught but like the same
thing in baseball like you know there
was people that were ahead of the test
for a long time you know I mean these
guys are they're pretty sure doing it
that never got busted did you watch the
whole part did you like to ask her if I
yeah I did
No mmm what you think I thought he
[ __ ] passed I thought he was he got
choked out for a second
I mean his arm just drop like yeah I I
don't have a problem I finished I have a
problem with Ben Askren spotty as he
comes in it looks like a dad bod I'm
like dude have just a little definition
that's all I'm just excited
I think he's gonna he's not working out
I don't know if he I don't think he was
just gonna run through a division like
everybody thinks it he know he was
getting destroyed I thought that was him
not [ __ ] tapping out dude if someone
hit me like that I would cry I would cry
I mean he is dropping haymakers on this
dude yeah yeah it's I mean he had a huge
cut in his head he was bleeding really
bad uh I mean like Rob Lawler's always
has controversy in his fights I would
like to like to have seen that
continue you don't think he tapped you
don't think he passed out well or
whatever we're calling it impasse like
in real time when I watched it I thought
it was a wrap and then when I saw the
replay on my oh no he was totally fine I
mean it wasn't even under goes yeah but
that's the only thing that happened I
mean he'd never tapped his arm tap cuz
he was out right but that's the thing
wrestling it without real time though ya
know in real time you could see why that
happened do you think he was out or do
you think he I didn't see it okay do you
we can you find that video okay yeah
I've just heard everyone say that they
don't think he was I think it was for
when is on but then but then his arm
wasn't you know it dropped like that
once and then he is oh that's a flash
knockout do we see how would flash
knockouts or Suns out for a second but
they they're all that is the one thing
about the UFC that they really do that I
like they err on the side of caution
yeah I'm good you watching boxing now
and you see this guys on what they call
queer streak that's a term and they just
let him go back and fight he just well
this guy was on [ __ ] Boulevard
come on I live in LA now it's it's yeah
here we go it's sensitive Chad
watch this Oh ready go watch his arm
watch his arm he's dead
like when you slow it down it looks like
he's he's put it down himself when you
play in real time it drops right in slow
motion can do that yeah oh you do that
slow motion porn so worse am i right
everybody here we go
seed slow-mo dude that's slow-mo that's
slow-mo he looks out to me was he doing
like a thumbs-up right Gary did to the
raft and then he stopped it right there
and then Lawler looks at him like what
the [ __ ] did you just do
I saved your life why do they keep
slowing it down it's annoying
yeah the way right after when he's like
why that doesn't look like us but I can
see how the ref thought that and to stop
it yeah and that's how fighters are
though they always are like why you were
out Oh
Askren for god it's like everyone has
been talking to all this [ __ ] about all
this time well dude I mean you're going
to look great to like a top five guys I
should right listen it's impossible to
look like you're just unless you are the
john jones guy who's just you know i'm a
dad who he claims to be I know he's
never been a great striker like Zoe I
think that games he's an old-school
fighter I'm dying I'm I'm excited to see
how it goes I mean they're you know I
mean like he's in the same division as a
guy who'd just destroyed Woodley yeah
like dude who's man I mean a new champ I
don't even know his name so yeah I mean
that guy looks like a murder of murder
more importantly what about your boy
Diego Sanchez
now he's not a boy make you were Mickey
golf for life
throwing Johnny random shot no research
because you know we're making golf for
life here dog as Johnny pointed out he
didn't wait the full five minutes last
time so no we're gonna let him go
because I push you a little hard but
that one is a hard five dog as a solid
five in the town [ __ ] around on that
one hard to watch and why don't you
biting what really good I like you I
like it it means he's got spunk that
kitties yeah he's he's punching to the
bone dog that's [ __ ] try to finger his
butthole
I don't want watch me good
that's my move that's what I do that's
what I do I suck your dick I don't know
what happened he said he just got gas
because he lost all his energy from the
weight cut and then he like had passed
out the night but the day before and
then just hey he passed out the night
before day before yeah oh man that's
never like this is the problem in
susannah Mickey butts like this is what
they're doing they're trying to get down
these smaller weights and it's hard man
yeah did he'll be back ain't no day yeah
he's gonna be back but sure we love him
and you know what dude if you gotta lose
somebody that's you know we I like that
guy yeah yeah
no bomb bomb and he's [ __ ] batshit
crazy yo what that fight cuz you're
fighting a legend yeah
anyone that steps in a ring I think is a
little off MMA fighters are hardcore
porn stars ooh
hardcore dude no I'm just saying to let
someone punch you or choke you the port
starts doing it - yeah they are yeah but
that's in a different you or me that's
in a different round like jerking off to
it that's what this that was your mother
because there are moms that are points
or mean like that's your mom and that's
what she does so bizarre that's that's
your listen honestly no it's also
curious you just had a kid and it like
like that kid eventually is gonna
believe it Google in I think she's so
funny like she's cool but like the next
day she was like come watch me suck dick
on my snapchat and was like her poor
baby's gonna know that like the day she
gave society's view of filthy dirty
I think porn is the ultimate female
sport I think it's the number one female
sport outside porn
she's a Hall of Famer she's a d1 player
she should gone straight to the league
and it's just like that I look at porn
more sport than I do actually like like
this filthy thing I feel like women
should do porn and get in the kitchen
and that is it yeah how you gonna eat
[ __ ] it I'm in the book someone said I'm
all in on this oh she's the one that did
videos right after China
I'm following get back to work
I say get that baby working on the phone
well she's always know that's her ex
he's also important I'm a big fan can
you tell he's also but I listened to her
podcast more than that I more than I and
she was books
oh that's really a plug for her I'm
alright book and Pete have people laugh
as knowing yeah I can't I'm illiterate
oh yeah you know you know who should
help you write it you know you know get
your buddy Scott over there to help ya
guys smartest [ __ ] such an [ __ ] whoa
okay ladies and gentlemen coming back
from the penalty box about Cody I feel
bad for that day well he's got three
losses now two to Dillashaw now this I
just think he like had a bad game
playing with that like he got he's too
crazy he wanted to go and bang and kid
you were you doing all right in the
world dude you were doing it right now
round but he has no head movement he
just gets into these he's a lot taller
he gets suckered into being in these
alley fights yep and that's how you beat
him yeah but he's easily lured like that
you know that banana leaves him right
into that same cave every time yeah he
just bites on that [ __ ] yeah and he
got got touched together hey hey can you
go and look up the next UFC fights
coming up because we want we want to get
back to our our dojo I think that he's
our guy I don't think he's gone no he's
gone but it's like dude now you got a
beat four or five gatekeepers or better
just to get back into a title shot
against somebody he almost has to clear
out the top of the division again I
think he has a loser
looking guy if he gets two wins right in
a row against some decent guys look at
the guy he's a good looking guy what are
we [ __ ]
I'm sure pinion was let's see one go to
next one I mean I'm like what do you
think it's the next that's a good fight
though what do you think it's the next
big one I don't know what I don't know I
don't know what else is on that card but
this one last weekend I was shocked
tonight I gotta say something I like
that fight that's a good card which one
go down that's got Israel iris yeah
that's a good car oh that's actually a
good power lemon what is that 13:13 let
me see if we can do it that's really
that's uh okay let me see if we can get
that it's like a month in the week five
weeks away let me see how whole car
journey how come my boy steep a hasn't
been back since he lost because they
treat him like [ __ ] you know why you are
here it I think that you have such a
great car and Mme WME want black
champions at the highest level oh he
says this every week look what you
started Chuck I tell you what I and you
guys can put any problem to rank put
this in the bank the UFC wants nothing
more than LeBron James to be the
champion and we've said it here and
we'll say it again right Scott are you
with me like cuz what is the heavyweight
division doing he's gonna fight Brock
Lesnar there's been like no more talk of
it these kids here really is getting
screwed he's getting screwed nobody
defended that belt more than he has in
the history of the heavyweight division
one loss and anybody else gets an
automatic rematch yeah they want the
biggest levels they want black champions
it's not allowing guys who are great
fighters look they haven't even updated
it go down they have tyron woodley still
number one [ __ ] garbage sigh I'm
obviously biased because the base from
Cleveland yeah I think they do you say
bisexual well I am in LA now okay so
steep a is a guy they could have
marketed
he's the everyday man he's a volunteer
fireman they could have really put that
guy over the top he could have been a
big draw for UFC and for some reason
there's no in Octavia T I can't even
pronounce it
there's no they're not using them I'm
sure we all agree and we're not from
Cleveland like he was great thank you
that's all I want to still is I mean he
literally hasn't fought since that right
yeah that's weird
it is weird really really sucks and he
deserves better
I mean it's not like an old guy either
you know it means yeah dude I feel but
like when you lose the belt it's so hard
to get back if we notice that man how
hard it is if you don't getting an
instant rematch yeah it is so hard to
get back there these guys lose their
look at Cody look at like almost any
champion they lose a belt you never hear
from them again it's so how it should be
though you have to do do you have seen
boxing you see guys get back to the Bell
but in in UFC they lose that it's so
hard to get back yeah can you imagine of
Apollo yeah the only class that that
seems to happen in his heavyweight
everything else is hard to get back
heavyweight day with the exception of
steep a exception of Steve a lot of
people have had the heavyweight belt for
one or two fights exactly but every
others every other weight class yeah man
you lose that belt it's a long he
dropped a lot right now cuz that guy was
ranked really low and then he lost him
so I bet Cody dropped a lot Cody needed
that 5cy site won't tell us though still
city's number two yeah oh yes he's got
the belt I'm saying there would never
been a rocky franchise if Apollo didn't
give rocky a rematch and let us not
forget a big right away huge part of the
show George sleep here officially we
talk here now done GSP I just feel like
he's coming back I feel like he's got
one more fight now I was gonna say he's
retired twice now the fighters are never
really I can see them trying to move
that fight with the Russian happen I
don't know man I don't think he wants
any of that I think he does not now but
he's gonna want money
like that's always fighters thing you
know I mean when they stop fighting like
it's hard for them to find [ __ ] to do
that's gonna bring them their same
income
I mean he'll go chase aliens and
dinosaurs
that's lucrative yeah so you want
socialism porn more importantly the
biggest sports story in the world is the
death of King Kong Bundy oh I know yeah
well we got down what's-his-face so
Perry the guy from the smack my [ __ ] up
[ __ ] video died and now we got King
Kong Bundy who does Mac my [ __ ] up boom
ba-ba-ba-ba-bom that guy died right
there Oh prodigy prodigy-man my [ __ ]
fire stunt cuz I'm a firestarter an evil
instigator dan I would have loved to go
I just I never did so heavily do would
never fly today Perry made a song called
smack my [ __ ] up yeah and it wouldn't
be a singer you know buddy hey crimes
were made on dww got a meeting with
shelf life
it goes I'm saying that's just a hard
lifestyle or something cuz those UFC I
mean WWE WF guys they're all dead at 60
oh you know if that they had stories on
that their lifestyle is like you know I
mean hardcore like all those guys Dyer
it was some WrestleMania it's like a
Wrestlemania maybe from 20 years ago
okay that literally every one of them
are dead yeah from one WrestleMania you
have a video called fake heat and most
of the Fight Club is fat Fight Club is
dead hmm so it goes rustlers comedians
oh no
slurs porn stars comedians we are now we
are under porn stars porn stars die
early oh dude ha dude they're still
making porn I'm jerking off to 2008 [ __ ]
most of those chicks are dead okay most
of the chicks are dead right they died
dude
last year mysteriously like five porn
stars died now I'm like those are
escorts and they all [ __ ] somebody no I
think it's rude well Google that porn
stars died I don't know where and dude I
know this is Brody said it is weird how
many hangings are going yeah did the
prodigy guy that hang himself Anthony
Bourdain did Anthony Bourdain and Kate
Spade Chris Cornell Barrington he hung
himself too yeah I don't know about that
look at that all them dead I beat off
for them oh is that yeah I think those
are just I know
did you beat off at the Gummer shyla
stylez right she's the one all the way
at the top did you beat off at the gums
did the teeth I'm all about teeth dawg
all of it looks like Caitlyn Jenner hate
the tea you hate the tea keep the teeth
I come jizz planner I love all keep the
teeth way to the Marcy oh yeah I mean I
want tea so big they never close her
mouth Sam gets hard when he watches the
mask yeah I love hija the donkey in
hee-haw corn on the cob teeth I thought
we were about to watch porn scary here
so is scary
has anybody seen I know we talked about
yesterday but have you seen the Michael
Jack
dude you're gonna get mad at you I just
finished it today did you yeah I woke up
it's crazy I your thoughts
I believe those kids 100% yeah cuz it
Oprah had something to do with it right
season either and just tell me one of
the stories or something she did the
wrap-up show no cuz she came out and was
like I see nose he's gonna get a lot of
heat for it with Oprah she watched it
and she says I want to talk to these
guys she like believed him
yeah there's no way you don't believe
that believe her like school in Africa
is doubt riddled with [ __ ]
accusations of pedophilia Oliver Frank
she hung out with all the time that
[ __ ] dude in Brazil she did a big
story on just got busted for baby
farming Oh
David Geffen she's friends with [ __ ]
the guy Harvey Weinstein kiss dick so
crazy the color purple she was great in
the color but see that's the thing
though yeah Oprah clean up your own
backyard
when you get that big your shader
shadiness
okay back to Michael okay this dude he
pimped kids
I blame Iran people you're against how
come you don't want to talk about
Michael Jackson I don't want to talk
well because I be honest with you man
Jason does a lot of jokes about [ __ ]
kids no I just want to hear your reason
that's why I don't want I didn't know if
you liked how does it's a lot of trauma
well our kids getting [ __ ] up and it
just makes me uncomfortable Michael
Jackson did do the Space Jam soundtrack
so this connects this punch of a Brian
yeah and LeBron LeBron to the connection
cannot you got it Sam's comedy always
has UFC fighters come and I'm always
assuming that they're on your guest list
every time and they always buy tickets
and you don't even know that these
people are there nobody tells me but
like it can be a porn star when nobody
told me oh well I don't know him horn as
well as whatever but Eddie Alvarez came
last week and he was super
grumpy to his friends that's me newsroom
Blake Griffin was there last time he
would tell me well I was so confused and
I was like are you in the guest list and
they always look at me like what are you
talking about and he's like no I'd like
to buy three tickets samtcy Blake
Griffin he was at the last one too he
was he sat in the back I would have told
you I would obviously everyone has seen
him too you know who else was there he's
but that's happening like three times
now like Kelvin Gastelum was there he
bought ticket dry a favor about tickets
should I come get you off stage like I
don't know where there's always refs all
the UFC refs come I don't know it's
random you're so cool Sam and you make
it so it's Rogan they want you they
actually he said he was there to see
Russell Peters though yeah okay so it's
not me thank you and then Eddie brings a
lot too and job to imagine Ellen Oh
Eddie Bravo brings like everything is
the best he's so funny he's a crazy
wonderful human being
Mack I love this kid dude that guy's
like I can't come on show I'm coaching
my son's baseball team like that guy
who's this guy Eddie Bravo oh he's a
nice guy yeah he's a great guy great
he's great why'd you say he was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't that's the
current ranking Gonzaga
is this college hoops yeah always a
March Madness coming up yeah it is I
love that no matter how much Duke in
Alabama I can't stand them no matter how
much they lose they're always in the top
five
we're Duke was the number one team
before yeah then they lost some major
guy yeah
therefore now they're done without on
yeah of course but they'll be fine in
the tournament you think he's coming
back
yeah what
if I was him I'd be like I need a raise
yeah I want me to come well my favorite
thank you google scion caught asking for
money you know he did and now that and
then he goes to do canna freaky i'ma
free yeah that's what I said no Zaya
they said Diane asked for money
employment for some people and housing
that's what this sounds like blue chips
with the way that was what the story was
that he was asking for on you and he
goes to do for free yeah him and RJ
berry yeah they all go there for free
when they were all asking for money
never do some same thing with Alabama
Alabama has had Cooke players come out
go oh yeah man we got paid some uh we
got we yeah we got paid money and I
don't know mm no I hope they get paid
they should get paid but the notion that
these other schools are getting lit up
there was the wire tab that's what I'm
saying it was on a wire tax they were
saying people are smearing I am today is
fluctuating interest rates kidding yeah
is this what a punch rug sponsored by
guys go to Quicken Loans Quicken Loans
for your cheap loans Dan Gilbert
yes of course and then he goes to Duke
for free yeah dude go watch blue chips
with Nick Nolte it's all real you guys
can find out I make some money on
whether kelp whether Coach K will ever
get accused of anything at bet D s I bet
the aside for all your buddy need to go
to bet DSi use the promo code punch 25
and you will get twenty dollars betting
cash even 25 or 25 dollars betting cash
and you will whatever you deposit they
will double up to $500 bet TS I was in
the Michael Jackson documentary do some
conspiracy [ __ ] with them but you can
bet on everything are these UFC games we
got the NCAA tournament coming up oh I'm
like one in the NFL Draft will get
Tebow's feelings on that whole thing um
you name it you can bet on it
ah you could done the UFC the last card
we got cards coming up right now they
got a a F
AAI football you got a really love
betting when you're betting AAF football
by Richardson covenant you know whoever
touches the thing is like eight starting
up its game kind of crazy you can do
anything you want you bet it's a bet DSi
help our friends out they help the show
you can Brett the presidential election
yeah come on no man you could punch 25
guys Oh Carla Murray number one you know
you know I mean David they would have to
get rid of Rose and they have to get rid
of Rosen we talked about that earlier
they are interested I wouldn't be
surprised the Giants weren't it's a
bunch of yeah now that's a few teams
interested the Jags were interested with
a big on sign fold yeah that's a lot
yeah no I'm faint caller Murray's going
number one somebody could trade up to
get um money gonna trade Rosen I mean
cuz Kingsbury even before he got the job
saying said number one pick and he's an
offensive minded guy too
well maybe that's why they hired him
that's why I brought him and again like
we were saying earlier when you get the
job you want your own people in there
you know
yeah Rosen you're cool but the guy I
would want being my QB uh-huh his
caliber absolutely did somebody break it
down in laymen terms the Antonio Brown
situation like what exactly went down in
Pittsburgh with him I hear all kinds of
stuff I don't know he ate Big Ben that's
ultimately those two don't get along by
the way we know Big Ben's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yes he's been hallway until Lee
dude his head blew up so much cuz he did
great he was with his college coach he
made his college coach get out and pump
his gas well he went to Miami it's a
smile max yeah Wow but soda Antonio
Brown it's a rumor to a max school too
oh yes he did you're right he's off the
map too so they both kind of have that
chip on their shoulder working their way
up yeah and I mean atonia Brown was a
six six eight
so that's the thing I feel like they dig
butt heads and then the ownership
basically sided with Big Ben yeah you
got to because he's your quarterback
yeah nah nah but they told they said big
big band has 52 kids he has to take care
of but that's what the GM said one of
them said that and everyone everyone was
kind of like what a lot of kids to know
he's calling the team like the Chargers
quarterback who has all those being the
team kids he has to look after Antonia
Brown all these other dudes never kind
of like dude we're all grown man here
yeah been a-been ain't on that high of a
pedestal so where does he go I mean like
Raiders Raiders get him if they keep car
the car you go after I heard they were
shopping them this weekend and of course
they Z that's insane
they tried to Mack you know say they of
course they could trade car I think it's
jump get him a line or get him somebody
to throw to oh by the way next year the
draft in Las Vegas we punch-drunk will
be definitely going we're gonna be we're
gonna go to the NBA Summer League we're
gonna get ourselves a [ __ ] Airbnb
house we're all gonna stay there Johnny
pay for it
Scott put it on the company card Scott I
could probably get his press passes yeah
yeah hey Diane needs to be in a dunk
contest next he well he well he will be
welfare okay good
Aaron just walked off the show that's
never happened before the director
holy [ __ ] don't quit
I put Aaron in the penalty box you can
he's going to the penalty box
yeah that's what we call the bathroom
yeah dude we're gonna go but yeah I'd
love to go to Vegas
Kyle Murray do two five ten and 1/8 or
eight or whatever it was that was
actually good I'm saying he's going
number one this draft is trash if it was
if he doesn't is great that's not the
Sadie's read and that's why I'm just
gonna say if he doesn't go number one
that's gonna be a DN probably both uh
but those aren't sexy drafts the drafts
that are sexy is when it's 3q B's at the
top the thing that running bad and all
guys love is like now there's like they
I think they like it when you don't know
who's gonna go number one there's a
question
so people tuned in more when it's like
okay it's gonna be Andrew Luck he's
gonna go number one [ __ ] it yeah I mean
you almost always know last year wasn't
it the 3q B's back-to-back-to-back Rosen
a Baker Baker Mayfield
that's uh that's Triple E nice boy Baker
we hung out with him oh is that right
yeah we two weeks oh right and Chandi
knows him I did it I go holy Sh I go you
Baker Mayfield he goes mmm I couldn't
dude you're making me loose yeah
Baker Mayfield you wouldn't even look at
us yeah yeah I broke it down right there
it is any letters that's that looks like
me before cocaine right me no Baker yeah
that's dope yeah no dude I was a
good-looking guy back in the day there
was a time where I was considered
[ __ ] so shut up hilarious you lost
weight though dude hey Baker man I know
but I'm tenacious the king yeah
do you look at that when we were on the
UH I got figure out this name for the I
want to call it the it was social just
worried but that would be disrespectful
to Brody that's Mark Henry the World's
Strongest Man oh is that him
that's a lot of weight yeah he'd be a
wrestler right yeah yeah we know he's
done we went to some barbecue place and
he was just hanging out of course he was
there right I'm surprised he is you have
a barbecue barbershop mmm that's racist
no it's not racist that's not racist but
here's where it gets racist and call it
Blackie's but I won't take the idea I
love it though but it would be weird to
be in your ribs and theirs so what do
you think right now who goes number one
whose shoes number two they gotta be
excited about the fact that both of my
actually fall to them yeah probably who
was number two who is number two Niners
they got that mark I love Murray going
number one I'm saying none of this is
sexy yo Josh Allen is joke kid baby
stealing my test suite ran a four for
142 at 260 yeah that's crazy right a
great name that's what's been happening
evolution good visas he's 63 to 65 a 24
for one unbelievable yeah only one
running back ran faster than that a DK
Metcalf oh he make you - yeah like
42-inch vertical like six for 230 and
round like a 4-3-3 yeah he'd be Julio
Jones and he's 96 three and that Limon
Beto 1% body fat
oh yeah percent body fat but his hands
are like stones supposedly like that
receiver that big and fast big and fast
but he can't catch supposedly oh you're
like this Sam ESPN's Mike Santo on
Monday pointed out the Oakland Raiders
are a potential landing spot for Johnny
Manziel Wow
man yeah I thought is that really I dude
I believe in second chances bro this is
like third chance because the CFL caught
them no banjo sandwich well you have
either that might be a potential landing
spot I wasn't yeah where they come join
he told him not to throw the ball so
hard yeah that's crazy
he has a good connection with the head
coach John's root on well how would John
Bruton and a crouton
Wow hey yeah John croutons like the it
was it no sorry John gluten yeah what he
[ __ ] a crouton so he said that you guys
might rake our that's what they're
saying I'll and get whoo-whoo
now you're not gonna you never ever
replace clean that's all I'm saying but
he's a Raider dude he's got Raider
attitude so was a Khalil man you never
replace him well here's a reason our
defense soccer we saw defensively and
theories that the NFL went to the
Raiders go if you [ __ ] have two
shitty seasons we'll make sure you get a
place in Vegas and that way the Rams
could try to take LA and so that's what
they're doing
that's my do they have one more season
left for with last one the last one well
the fact that they got the Super Bowl
might be interesting they're gonna have
one more shitty season the Raiders
that's why they gave Jon Gruden a
10-year contract go listen we'll give
you a 10-year contract you don't worry
about getting fired we need you to be
bad for these two years you're gonna
take some heat but that's okay dude that
kid that quarterback for Buffalo is good
yeah he's the same size as cam like he's
a good quarterback - he ran like a 4 or
I would draft that guy that's where back
when Mac went to Buffalo couples where
shady [ __ ] happens you should move there
look at that dance he's doing as he
thinks furies down I know and then he
got up like The Undertaker yeah that's
when I was like he's on Royce I want I
wanna go see if they fight again I love
the first fight oh I know but they were
standing they're gonna put a fight in
between that now like I hate when they
do that like when this strike when the
iron is hot yeah we don't want to see
you guys fight someone else then fight
each other you don't mean like that
raises the chance of somebody losing
boxing great it's been great I feel like
the UFC forced them to do that and now
the UFC's kind of faltering and boxing
is like oh hell yeah right now I like
that competition that made boxing like
[ __ ] we got to give free fights yeah
that's good free fight what's his name
for PC P P P Diddy PBC what is it what's
his name yeah what it one's up L Haman
you think they'd come back the combines
[ __ ] what do you mean like what do you
mean really like some people have shitty
combines they'd be great NFL players so
now it is but I feel like it Oh them for
the majority like you know I mean 70% of
the time you can see with who the good
players are it's a 30 I heard something
crazy you know why and this is totally
true you know why they call you and let
you know they're about to draft you why
do you know why they make that call why
to make sure you're alive oh really
yeah so they don't draft the dead person
yep has that happened I don't know but
that's literally why they call and go
like hey we're about to take you with
our next pick are you can we made you
breathing to make sure you didn't die
last night we don't waste a [ __ ] pick
oh my god that crazy you just blew my
mind it's big I was watching Rich Eisen
at the draft and
and he said that by the way that's why
they do that I'm like wow that makes
[ __ ] total sense I met rich Isaac hey
are you still alive
yeah if you are we want you to play for
us exactly yep yeah that's nuts right
yeah it's crazy
unless someone's died no no I mean in a
hundred years of football well not if
someone dying but the call like that's
become such a cool part of the draft as
when they get that call yeah and I can
see that gum let's just call make sure
he's alive uh-huh I didn't know that's
why they did it but the call is now like
a cool part yeah it's a part it's become
a part of the tradition but in in its
origin they're like yeah before we get
this guy like in the 70s and 60s and
[ __ ] let's make sure this guy's still
kicking around so I'm excited I think is
gonna be I mean I don't know what's
going on the Raiders I'm just gonna just
take a step back and go once we get to
Vegas
I'll start caring because you'll care
next year for now you're for now so
baseball it's getting these a little
baseball a little baseball
oh so Bryce Harper Aaron so happy
Bryce Harper signs this deal I call it
the most [ __ ] deal I've ever heard
in sports ever I mean so many thirteen
years three years million no opt-out no
trade you guys are married let's play a
game called I like on during how many
years till this this is an albatross on
the Philadelphia Phillies put that two
years go over by the way I don't think
it's the worst deal think Bobby Bonilla
z-- was the worst deal of all still
getting paid I know well it wasn't the
deal it was that they ran out of money
the Mets went bankrupt at that yeah
because I had no real did they had to
prorate they didn't have
the money I didn't know that it wasn't
like the contract was an albatross it
wasn't well it wasn't that it wasn't
that much money but they went bankrupt
they're like hey look we don't have the
30 million right now we'll give you a
million a year for the next 30 years
okay all getting paid Bobby bunny is 56
years old he hasn't played and you know
dude
they say when Bryce Harper's deals done
he saw he'll have four more years ago in
30 50 39 who doesn't 35 he gets a
million - yep a year that's gotta be the
greatest kid right
his job is to go to the mailbox oh wow
that's wrong damn I was just guessing I
was just using that as a number you know
I me buddy I guess it was 30 did the
funniest was like remember when the
Glenn Robinson was on the bucks and he
goes I want a hundred million dollars
and nobody in the NBA it asked for a
hundred million bucks yet and he told
the Milwaukee Bucks I want a hundred
million dollars and he goes I bought the
team for 80 million yeah like are you
out of your mind right now
like I paid 80 million dollars for this
team ten years ago everybody is one guy
wants a hundred he hasn't played since
2001 what were you doing in 2001 can you
guys remember 2001 yeah I was valet
parking in 2001 I was learning how to
fly planes were you yeah Wow I went to
my landover lanham Montreal I was a new
face of comedy year before you with
Kevin Hart Kevin Hart was oh one you
were at Kevin R yeah I was to still have
our book what happened to Kevin Hart I
know what happened to me
greatest sports show of all time oh yeah
thank you Sam
I love it who's on mine Corey Holcomb
all those year can young can dr. ken
Webb okay
new faces yeah dr. ken was a new face
yeah he's probably still doing doctor
[ __ ] yeah Oh cuz that was Dublin's was
still going he was doing doctor [ __ ]
yeah but now mine was a Kevin Hart deer
a deer a Davis Dean Edwards Dean Edwards
is great
mr. Connor used to ride the [ __ ] the
Apollo open a new phase was doing the
black guys first she was all you should
joke that's you literally go dude you
sure heard what I just a good joke or
not what man you be the judge I said no
you're hitting the box
bro hit the box you a racist a race I
said racist joke I never said it was
good a racist joke okay tried deliver it
right this time
no he was building like all the new
faces in 2001 it was like Kevin Hart it
was DeRay Davis yeah and I go what is
this just for Laughs new black faces I
like it
[Applause]
hi you're on with punching sports how
can we help you yeah finally got on here
yeah what's up
who is it from to come along oh yeah I'm
out there this weekend come see Sarah
coming up you ready all right dude thank
you so much and support so I just wanted
to say one thing
I knew Isiah Thomas you went to Curtis
high school and to come Washington you
know that's a different I promise and
when you said he was all about you know
that locker room [ __ ] you're talking
about sure let's go with it let's go Lee
please don't swear eat Oh squeeze me he
was all about that he's all about the
locker and it's one fader I don't have
like a big spiel but I just want to say
he was all about what you were saying
you were right like I'm from Tacoma and
I knew that I went to Curtis high school
and I yea dude he's the real deal bro
and hopefully he doesn't staying at the
Nuggets because I'm from Denver and I
grew up you know with the Denver I mean
I grew up with the tombo and hopefully
he doesn't man
Denver's good dude good they have
everything you need
they were sneaky this year they have
they have a nobody talking about her
that no how do you pronounce this name
no no cage no chick okay you're
assassins you have a bunch of guys if
you need shots when the when the clock
is coming down I mean you're multiple
shooters you have multiple golden I grew
up in the golden era I was there when
Allen Iverson got drafted and we had
Anthony deck how much better can you get
you know know when they trade it for I
mean when they were they were garbage
then dude that's not the golden era the
golden era is way back in Alex English
days or even with wumbo days but dude
that was a garbage Erica's [ __ ]
Carmilla Anthony was a garbage guy was
all about him then he got Helen Anderson
who Billups yeah Chauncey Billups well
that was before you know that was before
he cut the braids look he got the
braised he was good right I don't know
man do that one nugget scene with JR
Smith and Carmela was great they were
fun they went to the Western Conference
final they were the most 10 in the
league always put you over on the
tattooed
you need birdman to win that contest
it's a Rando so there yeah when it comes
that he's a ringer cuz we went to the
heat they because liked him I was liked
him know he was a great teammate Chris
Anderson yeah I was I could yeah and
white chocolate two men for such a short
over his highlight reel you Jason
William Haines did watch his highlights
on YouTube
I mean it's unbelievable I can't repeat
unbelievable he's still that he had a
behind-the-back pass where he would go
like this way and then hit the ball with
his elbow and pass it that way he was so
[ __ ] fun to watch you could actually
watch white chocolate is forty 40 and
over league playing with these old men
he's still doing that [ __ ] wonder why he
never like really went crazy well cuz
their daddy no one from the am one
really you know I mean because lady
bright became that kind of player but
you know he played high school
basketball with Randy Moss yeah they
were tomorrow
mark lock head Oh
Johnny look up some of the white
chocolate highlight reel yeah it's
[ __ ] dope moths had ups you know I
mean that's why he would do that you've
been moths you know they're actually
saying while white chocolate Sons sweet
- really oh really
they're saying he's a pretty pretty
quick good player white chocolate and
then even back to Florida though he went
to oh yeah he was great at Florida did
he go and then Mike Bibby came in he was
so great at passing where'd he go when
Mike baby came well Mike Bibby was a
point guard after but where did he get
Kobe yeah Buster that's him crossing
Kobe dude this guy's court vision was
just oh yeah Oh guarding I know this is
bad oh yeah I forgot he had absolutely
this is bad audio but this is sweet
visual mark I was watching a white
chocolate school [ __ ] oh my
favorite movie and he had a crossover
too baby
give it a Weber man what a great one to
look at what a great one - those guys
were they never could get past the lake
no they gonna body Weber up Asia
[Music]
he was so good behind the back - ever
talks about age crossover Ryan I talk
let's tight speaking the AI
that's him Oh a I oh that was good money
yeah yeah as soon as you said it - what
a savant yeah he was great I was loved
watching was he always with kings did he
go to Memphis after yeah Mike Bibby came
in and that's when they kind of took
they were to the finals I met Mike Bibby
in Arizona in Arizona Utah how big why
do you want to hear it great Mike Bibby
story Bibby is huge now you know I was
like fat no like my so three years ago I
was that I was playing a house of comedy
in Arizona stop Brian were and you'll be
there when Zim so he was at this life
its life center plus and he's playing at
hoops and I go that's [ __ ] Mike Bibby
so I go up to him I go hey you're Mike
Bibby goes yeah man he's trying to blow
me off he's talking to his friends I'm
like I used to own your jerseys like all
cool man I was like nah man I used to
wear at the high school I loved you man
he's like yeah that's cool and then he
just puts his back to me I'm like I just
want to say I was a fan and then he
whispers to his friends and they all
start laughing at me okay they're making
fun cuz like the white dude just trying
to like be cool and talk to him yeah yes
yeah I just walked away like with my
head down you think it was race in
racism and why I was gonna be in
pathetic I was kissing his ass and yeah
but now he wasn't cool at all but I felt
so lame his Vince Carter Hall of Fame
yes yes yes totally
easily and I think part of it is is
long-term absolutely no I think I think
his longevity is great but his people
forget how great he was
I mean Olympic gold medalist in the
Olympics so bike yeah one of the
greatest dunkers of all time best dunk
contest
performance of all time in my pee
receive the dunk in the Olympics over
that seven yeah of course grace dunk of
all time literally angel over a step and
it's someone in this year's dunk contest
tried to do that yeah I was like the guy
standing still I'm like when was that
Chuck yeah my Vince did that in a game
he was in motion oh yeah
he what oh yeah right you like anyone
from a high flyer like our age yeah no
he's a little younger but still three
nubs in yeah I got D way didn't exchange
jerseys with him that would have been
cool to rookie I have a million times
already
well Davey way wasn't doing that before
a business party he's like fear no I
didn't do it Vince Carter though they're
too [ __ ] geez I cannot wait to see
Dwayne Wade in the big three next year
there's got to be something like let's
say your D weight or somebody like that
there's like you know this is your last
season yeah you know you're not making
the [ __ ] postseason or you don't
really have a shot at that it's got to
be a fun farewell lap of just like I'm
playing basketball twenty two more times
in my life yeah and this is my last time
at Madison Square Garden this is my last
time at the Staples Center does it as a
working I mean not without buying a
ticket to go see a [ __ ] boxing match
or something like that you know there
has to be something that's kind of like
just no I would say romantic but but you
kind of have to kind of step back and go
that bomb and this is I can't [ __ ]
believe this
died two deaths in their life the first
one is when their career is over
yeah the second one is a divorce no yeah
that makes sense I think about it it's
like you know when you're gonna die it's
almost like you know your career is
gonna end you're just gonna make the
most out of it you appreciate it
I mean see that's the thing I feel like
that's why a lot of boxers and UFC
fighters come back because it's Wow as
in the professed shark Liddell it's
nothing that can replace that yeah but
nothing you can go into regular lime a
table is now doing theaters like he's
the smart one
yeah no sure Brandon shop and making
more money now than he ever would have
is if I
right but I mean again who did Vince
Carter play with on that Carolina team
come on Jamie
that's right can I ask a favor I think
yeah I mean dude he really was the
beginning of a power for so or dismiss
play with Russia no cuz Rasheed play
with Stackhouse okay there yeah yeah it
was two groups of the two like that yeah
Trail Blazers rusher okay hello so I got
it so that members of Tacoma guy you
just talk you okay yeah so what just
happened there that was so weird you
know the guy you were just talking to
what he's gonna drop some info yeah what
is going on yeah what's going on I don't
know you just hung up yeah right
question I think Seattle is the next
team that Seattle Vegas is a tuna
retaken Norlin you're either gonna get
in New Orleans or Memphis God will they
be the Sonics again yes they kept the
name right yes yeah that's that's gotta
keep the name yes I think it'll be
sooner than later - okay thanks man this
one of my prediction go Sonic's Seattle
gets a team and then that's where Kevin
Durant goes he goes back to the team
that drafted him and like 45 would you
say that is one of the lowlights of
LeBron James's career getting pushed to
go play deal I mean that right there
will be played forever on why he was
[ __ ] sometimes [ __ ] checked out I
mean that is crazy
I was [ __ ] LeBron I'd be like okay I'm
not the beat of dudes ass and after
actually after oh no that wasn't the
Clipper game but last night the Clippers
were going out
he got into I love Patrick Beverley oh
yeah he's got crazy like when you see a
chick with that look in your eyes like
that chick is good in bed like it's that
kind of like their water they're wild
and they will burn the place down
local buck wild right yeah there we go
he lives on the edge and he's easily
pushed over
I hope the Clippers free sign him
because I don't want to play him he's
like I took Westbrook oh yeah he blew
crazy dude man does not give a [ __ ] he
does not and then having him a he's a
guy that like before the game when he
warms up he's got the knife and he's
just playing that game real quick just
get in the zone right in my trash oh
then we got mini montrezl have you seen
that guy that they signed it looks
exactly like montrezl what's his name
I don't even know half the name to the
guys on my team okay then there's who's
the guy that's the shooter we got from
Philly is insane but you know his name
even right it's on the flier heads on
the flyer Landry Shemin hey that guy can
ball that guy can I cannot believe I
cannot believe Philly gave him up dude
he's that good another way of just more
JJ reddick propaganda why that guy
wasn't sorry JJ was I don't get I don't
get you guys have muscala too right yeah
we give them to you right well then
people don't know why you guys made that
trade it was very simple that Beasley
and Luke Walton we're gonna throw down
right but what good music why couldn't
we just release Beasley
he's got released by you guys week why
couldn't we just say we'll keep zoom
Bock Beasley you're released
those are good shirts watch the Beasley
I don't have to make a trade of a nice
young sinner to release Beasley because
Magic Johnson's a [ __ ] idiot I can't
argue and his job is is when white
billionaires want to attract urban
people they hire magic and mags like
come on man what you're just gonna have
a good time right here you know and it's
just and you do have a good time yeah
but he I don't know why anybody thought
he'd be a good GM well he would see I
don't I haven't putting the blame on
magic yet cuz he got LeBron like that
was the first step yeah I mean hey what
a Snoop Dogg have to say I didn't know
he went off gave up his boobie in jail
for murder buddy gotta go be in anymore
Bob hated you that was not anything a
lot of [ __ ] gotta go whoa starting
with the coach
well he's white not like being called
VMware's ship all them [ __ ] are get a
slave ship and ship all this Wow
Stanford you didn't enjoy that he looks
like he was in the sitcom 2 to 7 with
Marla Gibbs black celebrities like to
look like psychic anybody can homies hit
me blow me up
right now I bet we could get him on the
show cuz snoop does anything he'll come
on
I guarantee snoop comes on back too
I'll be dying I'll be dead in four years
I cannot believe King Kong Bundy yeah
man I mean a heart attack or what
natural causes
yeah I mean he's [ __ ] hyper
dad Bundy dead macho man dead
who else am I missing everybody [ __ ]
Ultimate Warrior dad gave his own eulogy
Jake the snake you got it snakes dead
no he snakes actually it's gang fest he
is that skanks performing Jake Jake the
snake is gonna play the dojo soon get
the [ __ ] out that serious book me I want
to see their bad that's gonna be weird
it has no gray hair
bleach-blonde no Jake's alive he's doing
stand-up I think he is it skank fest
yeah I saw he was doing like church gigs
we Coco beware we're not on the thing I
commented on it and like look I mean
have we can have you sinned and God hey
we want to do it I mean I talked to him
when they were here a month ago talk to
them in person dude I'd love to go but I
haven't but then they release the flyer
what's everything that's on it and we're
not on it okay that means it's wrong you
guys are on it I can't read you had to
fly as always we guys are on it uh-huh
Brody's at it can you talk yeah yeah
well how come then my other podcast is
there yeah it said 10 boy hats at it but
it didn't say punch on you guys are
always weird to by Chad's there but not
too much back to back
everything's been about Brody every time
I don't use any of it says naughty shows
there but it didn't dude naughty shows
coming back it said international bad
boys was there yeah downtown everybody
the whole thing's coming back to a
stormy Dan show Tebow international bad
boys coming back I love I'm like
Hollywood I'm just remaking the classic
tripley's Viacom about how like I got an
AIDS test they said we're testing for
HIV one agent v2 I go I didn't know
there was a sequel but then again
Hollywood's making everything that
killed in the 90s right and people just
go oh like it's a guy hate it too
[ __ ] Hollywood that's good shield in
the 90 he's not dude I'm a Booker I
can't have this in our festival sumachs
[ __ ] who's my friend firstly I am i I
have I'm a gatekeeper oh we are the 23rd
we're doing the show March 23rd yeah
it's myself you Florentine nice and I
gotta figure out what what is alright
it's gonna be at the rec room I gotta
make that flyer tomorrow that flower
will be on the flyer it's the 16th okay
hey guys that's Michelle final thoughts
then three minutes we're gonna go around
the horn nany 23rd all right Jason tee
ball final thoughts right okay Chad hey
subscribe to my youtube channel
adventures in Argyle adventures in
Argyle adventures in Oread cast yes
awesome me and thank you all me Ruben
part only black dudes ever a follow me
on instagram yeah we look up his
Instagram this [ __ ] was on new
faces in 2001 right last time I was
there now me too me too
hashtag me too the guy ran it got me too
- did he really
Scott final thoughts for you sir nothing
okay honey what's up the plug Johnny
wants the plug go to the Laker what is
that a bomb a bomb
that's what church is all about right
they got go hard to paint on that stuff
and go to the Laker one yo oh this is
great
playoffs eastbound and down they don't
know
trucker hi Lisa
where'd you get this way and a short on
get that LeBron hey Luke Perry I'm
friends with his daughter she's a fan of
mine rest in peace Luke Perry
that's all I know I met her in Madison
Wisconsin please stop dying why'd you
post that one what is this
that's an ab workout god that just lets
us know that we're just monkeys throwing
[ __ ]
the fact is somewhat tits and ass we'll
just [ __ ] grind on a wall where are
they yeah great punch drunk it's
probably been the best episode we've
ever sign up for patreon right it's
probably the best episode we've ever
done I gotta be honest with you I wish
you just had endless and the podcast cuz
it will never be better than this
something-something calm I love it
taxi V chad zuma calm someone's down
there for two my taxis
I don't get paid so Chad zoo mock
everything